i ricavi di questo video più una parte
da meo aggiunta verranno donati in
beneficenza per l'emergenza coronavirus
se vuoi donare anche tu o se vuoi avere
più informazioni riguardo a questa
emergenza
puoi consultare tutti i link in
descrizione ecco a voi 30 cose da fare
in casa mi raccomando lascia un mi piace
per sostenere questo video e facci pure
sapere i tuoi consigli su cosa fare in
casa giu nei commenti
sei pronto iniziamo subito numero 1 fare
degli esercizi
stando tutto il giorno a casa è molto
importante fare un po di attività fisica
su youtube ci sono moltissime elezioni
per fare esercizi a casa oppure si sono
anche varie applicazioni per cellulare
che vi guideranno nel fare esercizi
numero 2 meditazione lo sapevi che
meditare riduce lo stress e l'ansia e
aiuta ad essere più sereni
potete utilizzare o delle applicazioni
per cellulare che contano il tempo
oppure su youtube ci sono delle
meditazioni guidate che vi guideranno
durante la sessione di meditazione
rilassatevi e cercate di svuotare la
mente e vedrete che poi vi sentirete già
meglio numero 3 scrivere in un diario o
in un'agenda potete pianificare le
vostre giornate quelle giornate di
studio di lavoro oppure scrivere i
vostri sogni i vostri obiettivi io lo
trovo molto rilassante e mi diverto
anche a decorare ogni pagina con degli
adesivi numero 4 stampa delle foto o
semplicemente salva le dei tuoi desideri
obiettivi dopo potrai creare un college
e se vuoi stamparlo e appenderlo nella
tua cameretta o nella tua agenda o nel
tuo calendario in america è molto
utilizzata questa tecnica e si chiama
avviso un board e aiuta a tenere a mente
quali sono i tuoi obiettivi i tuoi sogni
io la creo ogni anno e mi motiva
tantissimo nel continuare a inseguire i
miei sogni
numero 5 scrivi una storia breve puoi
sviluppare la tua creatività scrivendo
una storia breve di qualsiasi genere
poi se vuoi puoi aggiungere delle
immagini oppure disegnarle tu stesso e
farla leggere alla tua famiglia oi tuoi
amici e chiedergli cosa ne pensano
numero sei disegni a qualcosa e se non
sai di segnare come me
puoi seguire uno dei tanti tutorial su
youtube disegnare un'attività divertente
e rilassante che ti aiuta anche a
sviluppare la tua creatività numero 7
dipingi qualcosa secondo me dipingere
ancora più rilassante di disegnare puoi
utilizzare quello che voi acquerelli
colori a cera tinte ad olio e se non sai
dipingere come me segui pure un tutorial
su youtube numero 8 scrivi una lista di
cose che vorresti che si realizzassero o
che vorresti realizzare entro la fine
dell'anno
puoi scrivere i tuoi desideri o dei
viaggi che vorresti fare anche questo ti
aiuterà a tenere bene a mente i tuoi
desideri ed obiettivi numero 9 scrivi
una lettera ad una persona a cui vuoi
bene
nella lettera puoi scrivere cosa ti
piace di questa persona
cosa pensi che la renda speciale o
qualsiasi altra cosa di positivo ti
venga in mente di questa persona
vedrai che sarà felicissimo di ricevere
questa lettera è questo rafforzerà
ancora di più la vostra amicizia numero
10 scrive una lettera a te stesso del
futuro
puoi scrivere una lettera in cui
racconti come stai in questo momento
quali sono i tuoi sogni e desideri che
cosa hai fatto oggi
poi puoi conservare la lettera e
scrivere in che hanno riaprirla vedrai
quanto sarei sorpreso nel futuro di
rileggere tutte le cose che pensavi anni
prima mi raccomando ricordati di
scrivere la data così saprei esattamente
quanti anni sono passati numero 11
scrivi un'email a te stesso del futuro
questo è lo stesso concetto della
lettera però poi scriverla come i
mail la differenza è che puoi
pianificare quando riceverai queste
email e scrivere appunto il tuo
indirizzo email dove la riceverà il sito
che ho trovato si chiama mail nel futuro
punto com
sei pronto a scrivere un'email a te
stesso del futuro numero 12 scrivi tre
cose di cui 6 grato tre cose che ti
rendono felice puoi ripetere questo
esercizio ogni giorno per aumentare la
tua felicità e gratitudine verso la vita
numero 13 pratica il lettering per una
pratica molto semplice puoi scrivere su
google lettering e andare su google
immagini e copiare semplicemente i vari
caratteri per scrivere una parola o una
frase io lo trovo molto rilassante e mi
aiuta a decorare la mia azienda
[Musica]
numero 14 guarda un documentario su
netflix è sempre utile vedere dei
documentari se non avete netflix ci sono
anche dei documentari gratuiti su
youtube basta cercare documentario siri
pure il tema che ti interessa di più
numero 15 rivedi la tua serie preferita
ma in lingua originale o in un'altra
lingua
se hai difficoltà a capire la lingua
puoi sempre mettere i sottotitoli o in
lingua originale o in italiano questo ti
aiuterà anche a fare pratica imparare
una nuova lingua non nunsense world race
bowl numero 16 fai una maratona del tuo
creator preferito su youtube
se vuoi rendere le cose ancora più
divertenti puoi provare ad attivare i
sottotitoli automatici vedrai quanto fa
ridere a vedere i sottotitoli
completamente sballati rispetto a quello
che si sta realmente dicendo nel video
numero 17 gioca e dai attenzioni al tuo
animaletto domestico
sicuramente i nostri animali domestici
saranno felici ora che siamo sempre a
casa non dovranno mai separarsi da noi
quindi approfittiamone per giocarsi un
po e tarli più attenzioni fatemi pure
sapere nei commenti come si chiamano i
vostri amici pelosi numero 18
impara una nuova lingua sempre su
youtube ci sono moltissime lezioni
gratuite per imparare una nuova lingua
fammi sapere nei commenti che lingua
stai studiando in questo periodo numero
19 leggere ovviamente non poteva non
essere in questa lista leggi quel libro
che è lasciato da parte da un po di
tempo
oppure perché no rileggi il tuo libro
preferito numero 20 fai un po di ordine
e se già ordinata la tua cameretta
perché non provare a risistemare le cose
in un modo nuovo
numero 21 prova delle nuove combinazioni
di outfit e perché no magari puoi
provare anche qualche combinazione di
outfit bizzarro puoi anche farti dare un
voto dai tuoi genitori o dai tuoi
fratelli sorelle o a vizi e vedere come
reagiscono qua berlino non ha reagito
molto bene
[Musica]
numero 22 karaoke puoi fare qualche
sessione di karaoke con i tuoi amici con
la tua famiglia e perché no anche da
solo e super divertente
scrivi il titolo della canzone che
preferisci su youtube che poi aggiungi
la parola karaoke ci sono tantissime
canzoni da cantare in karaoke numero 23
fai un po di yoga e molto rilassante e
aiuta a distendere i muscoli si sono
varie applicazioni per cellulare o video
su youtube che possono guidarvi nella
vostra sessione di yoga numero 24 fai un
video con il tuo cellulare o videocamera
e poi divertiti ad evitarlo puoi
utilizzare dei programmi per cellulare
ad esempio io ho utilizzato imovie
oppure dei programmi per computer come
movie maker imovie che anche per
computer o poi cercare di programmi
gratuiti online
io lo trovo super divertente aggiungere
effetti e colori numero 25 impara uno
strumento musicale
puoi provare con delle applicazioni per
cellulare o sempre dei video su youtube
online numero 26 prepara una tisana o un
thè caldo e metti della musica
rilassante
ogni tanto fa bene rilassarsi e svuotare
un po la mente senza dover fare qualcosa
nello specifico numero 27 cucina
qualcosa magari puoi provare a cucinare
qualcosa che non hai mai fatto prima
oppure seguire qualche video ricetta
sempre su youtube
numero 28 prepara una caccia al tesoro
puoi chiedere a qualcuno dei tuoi
familiari o amici di preparare una
caccia al tesoro nascondendo qualcosa
dei cioccolatini delle caramelle delle
sorprese poi divertiti a trovarli numero
gioca a dei giochi di società o a carte
con i tuoi amici o familiari e sempre
divertente giocare ai giochi di società
e aiuta a passare del tempo assieme e
stare più vicini numero 30 prenditi cura
di te stesso può essere facendo un bagno
caldo o applicando una maschera per il
viso
io adoro prendermi cura della mia pelle
mi rilassa tantissimo mettere le creme
in viso o fare una maschera ma per
ognuno può essere qualcosa di diverso e
comunque del tempo che dedichi a te
stesso
numero 31 bonus approfittane per passare
del tempo con i tuoi cari non dare mai
per scontato il tempo che passi con le
persone a cui vuoi bene spero infatti
che questi consigli e diano qualche idea
in più per passare più tempo protettivo
con i vostri amici o con i vostri cari
sempre in casa fatemi sapere quale
attività vi è piaciuta di più e i vostri
consigli nei commenti
un bacio a tutti ea presto
[Musica]